i mean i could talk about five reasons
why
instagram is critical nowadays for guys
if they want to get chicks
but uh but yeah that's how me and fresh
uh met met through instagram and then we
started working together ever since but
um real quick i guess i can go into it
because i know uh rich your audience is
a little bit older
um so i'll go over the five things with
with instagram why it's so important
uh so number one it allows you to
talk to girls that you otherwise would
have never had the opportunity to speak
to right so like we all know that we
live in a globalized sexual marketplace
nowadays
um women have more options than ever had
before and the thing is is that if you
don't have a digital footprint in a
dating scene you are limiting yourself
because you can only cold approach so
many girls and this is coming for me as
a cold approach advocate you know you
know me and troy love
cold approaching girls so um
so you're going to be able to meet girls
that you otherwise would never been able
to meet and then on top of that like in
miami for example right we got a lot of
very attractive girls ig models whatever
that rub elbows with like celebs
whatever it may be
you're not going to catch those girls on
tender bumble and if you do see them at
a club they're going to be in the vip
so the only way you're going to like get
access to like these blue check mark
type chicks or these like very very
attractive women
is through instagram you know what i
mean we actually was able to network
with like
with like a high level tick tocker
through instagram she dm fresh
and then you know we're gonna do a
collab with her down the road but
otherwise he would have never met her
she lives in la
when she comes to miami she's hanging
out with rappers and stuff like that so
we would never been able to like
get access to her because like certain
girls just go to certain parties that
most dudes don't get invited to so
instagram gives you that ability number
four
it lets you and i'll just count down
from five number four lets you resonate
with a younger audience right younger
girls
so we all know here in the sphere that
you wanna typically if you can
you wanna be able to attract younger
more fertile women right more more
attractive girls in general and they
tend to be younger
so these girls nine out of 10 times have
are on instagram and use it pretty
religiously you know i mean we live in a
world now where like
you know i know girls that like if they
don't have a 200 likes on their
instagram they're going to delete
the picture right away so as an older
guy it gives you the ability to kind of
like identify with
younger women because let's keep it real
you know i mean i remember what it was
like before the cell phone and digital
media agent but a lot of these younger
girls don't like these girls like grow
up with cell phones ipads etc so
if you want to date younger girls you
need to be on instagram so you don't
shoot yourself in the foot
go ahead what's younger like what age
age range are you talking about because
i mean a lot of the guys
that complain about online dating
results are like
they're you know they're post wall
they're mostly single moms they're not
that attractive i mean
they're like you know if you want to be
with fives and sixes it's like shooting
fish in a barrel is what i've heard a
lot of guys say
today so what kind of age range are you
talking about that's a great question
i would say like any girl born after
like 1988
is more than likely gonna have some kind
of like social media presence or
older you know what i mean but like if
you want to date because i'm 30 and
everyone my age
is on ig heavy so younger than that for
sure and then even i know girls like in
their early to mid 30s that are
are all over instagram too how does that
compare with like tick tock because i
know that's a big one too like is
instagram
more dense for for that like is it more
beneficial to
use that to try to approach women or
does tick tock work too like
pick up girls for sure yeah okay so if t
talk is more like for for a younger
audience that's most like teenagers and
kids
yeah so girls i wouldn't really
recommend that because
they may be under age but for instagram
us 18
up to like 20 28 it's definitely that
range that you want to be in
and we have like a lot of older clients
that hey you know i'm out the game i
just got divorced
how do i get back into the game with
these younger chicks and for example
we say hey you know what you can attract
these tricks with lifestyle rather than
just like what i'm saying trying to hit
them at the club and
they don't know who you are they can see
your online presence and they hit you up
say hey you know what
i want to be part of part of that
lifestyle i want to come to that spot
and so on and so on so
missy in this case you can use lifestyle
to like try tricks like that um
and you're not in like age range you
could say okay yeah
talk is definitely uh for the younger
crowd we got kicked off tick-tock
because it was sterling we made some
videos about
like some other stuff we got kicked off
but uh but yeah so i would say if you
want to definitely date
younger girls you know having ig is
going to help you and guys i want to put
a disclaimer out there
you guys don't need our course at all to
get women at all like you don't you can
definitely get out there cold approach
uh use um you know conventional
methodologies to recruit women and get
girls
but we're just helping you guys put out
an all-out assault on the dating
marketplace you die so you lose because
we all know girls are fickle and flaky
more than ever before so to win you got
to work crazy volume
if you don't have an ig presence it's
going to only hurt you really you know
what i mean if you're not on there to
you know as another way to show
demonstrations of higher value which
i'll talk about here in a second as well
what kind of volume are you talking
about like um how much work is involved
because i know there's a lot of guys
that are kind of on the fence like i'm
not doing this
this is stupid i'm not going backwards
it took fresh a while
to to do yeah so quite fresh it's fun
because like that's
actually very very questionable because
at the beginning i did like a lot of
club posts right for two years
i'll go to clubs every night talk to
girls whatever and i got results
but it was not like what i wanted to get
in terms of like um
the skill so for example let's say talk
to 20 tricks i may get two or three
and that's me being generous you get me
however now
i spent time on my instagram literally
every single day i might have seen this
as well
that's why i'm on show with him i can
get three to five girls a day
every single day of my life now let's
head it up this way
so the the time is it something to set
this up change my life
completely because now it's kind of like
a foundation of a house you build it the
right way
you're going to get tenants coming to
your property and they're going to pay
you rent versus a
shaky foundation it's kind of like here
and there you might get some tenants but
they may leave because it's a bad
foundation
so in the same sense as a man if you
could build this up the right way
and it took me three years to do this
but we made the course into like a three
to six month
thing you could follow and once it's
done you're pretty much good to go with
females because
once again we must uh trap you with um
thirst traps and as guys we do we do it
through lifestyle yeah girl their strap
if you can define that just so people
get some clarity
yes so instagram tech talk are like the
the the land mines of torch traps
because every girl that wants to blow up
show either their like their ass or like
i'm saying their their
body parts and they kind of uh they will
keep it clean yeah
they kind of like glamorize their uh
their bodies they basically just show
themselves you know they were scantily
clad clothing
yeah they're shaking shaking their rear
end you know what i mean yeah we're
basically talking about
about like top of funnels so they can
send the thirsty betas kind of like
through the funnel to the only fans to
the
exact cam sites and all that stuff right
here's yeah for sure because there's a
lot of thottery going on in there right
like you're not really looking for
mrs meyer and gaines in there right now
right yeah no no not at all and i mean
like the thing is is that like
yeah one thousand percent rich like
girls put their stuff out there on
instagram on
uh tick tock whatever it may be to
funnel people right back into their only
fans or whatever it is
so they can get their paid content which
is like a viable strategy because we've
dated a bunch of girls that actually
make a lot of money off only fans
and that's how they that you know that's
how they do it they get these guys
funneled back to you know pay a
subscription for 20 a month or
buy pictures from them or whatever so um
girls like to thirst trap what their
bodies do stir strap with their
lifestyle so you're able to convey that
which uh that brings me actually to
number so so uh so we talked about the
two
two reasons why it's important so number
one you're able to
talk to girls you otherwise not been
able to speak to you're able to resonate
with younger women
and then number three it lets you uh
basically meet other high-value men
right so it lets you uh meet other guys
that
um you otherwise wouldn't have been able
to meet or get an interview with or
whatever it may be because
if you have a certain ig profile look
people are going to want to work with
you so fresh has been able to get us
like some pretty big interviews
we interviewed greg ferreira uh two days
ago who was a huge youtuber two million
subs
uh we were interviewing stunt lifestyle
tonight and he's a big youtuber prank
prank youtuber here in miami as as well
uh with millions of views
yes sarah j sarah j uh we got
uh hotep jesus coming um we got a bunch
of people coming
and it's because we have uh especially
fresh has a good idea so people are like
yo we want to work with you you know and
then let me ask that as well
and rich you know this too right at a
certain point
women aren't the main interests anymore
it's kind of like you surpassed that
level
and there's levels to this so for
example at some point
even becoming a high-value meal you're
going to meet guys that actually have
business mindsets
guys are doing big things you know maybe
like part of a car group whatever it
might be
you want me to circle because one
there's more clients for you if you have
a business and then two
never networking with these people you
get invited to certain events that you
never would have
done by yourself you got to go to
different places so it's kind of like a
access to like a bigger world outside of
yourself basically
and guys just a quick reminder feel free
to call in guys we're here to answer
questions about instagram dating
whatever it may be
we want to help out help you guys out
give you as much free value as we can on
this broadcast
um so going back so you're able to
network with other high value guys
uh and then another reason why instagram
is so important is because something
called passive demonstration is a higher
value
so um i can't i mean
me and fresh have different dating
strategies but what what fresh does is
he'll meet a girl
and even if she wasn't like too open to
meeting him when he first met her
he'll give her his ig what will happen
is she'll follow him and she'll start
looking at his stories and everything
like that
and what he's been able to do is he's
been able to reel these chicks back in
because they'll still start
you know he's you know building
attraction through his posts through his
lifestyle and then the girl will hit him
back up and like message with like
a smiley face or a heart eyes or when
are you going to take me there where are
you going to do this
blah blah and it's able to re-initiate
conversation so i'll give you guys a
quick example
uh when we were first moving into this
building here in miami
uh which this building is filled with
like hot chicks everywhere man but
scary yeah when we're first like moving
furniture into the studio everything
like that
this this really attractive girl fresh
meadow she was being flaky you know
blowing them off whatever it may be but
he got her instagram
so she started looking at all her
stories and then eventually she went out
with him on a date
and when she went out on a date with him
to the car show to a car show when he
she went on a date with him she admitted
hey um you know i'm dealing with this
guy right now he's but he's like having
some financial problems blah blah blah
just like you always say
uh rich right she's getting ready to
monkey branch the next guy because
things are looking a little shaky baby
so it's like
you know i said so she so she goes and
meets with him but if he did not have
his instagram there
right or worse yet like he does what i
normally do which i kick girls to the
crib immediately
he wouldn't have went out with her but
since he had that door open
and he was able to passively you know
just like passive income
show higher value she went out with him
anyway because
um and a lead that otherwise would have
probably been cold
stayed warm so that's another reason why
instagram helps because it does a lot of
the work
for you because so many girls put such a
stake on instagram go ahead first you
guessed them
yeah not only that rich but for example
guys that lost their ex or whatever are
had a bad breakup
it's funny they want the ex back right
but they don't know how to so in this
scenario here
uh what you could do is is you don't
block her right away you don't like
delete her number you keep her in the
funnel because all this is a funnel it's
like an email list
you get some opt-ins people opt into
your email and from there you always
send them value
and after a while then you know what let
me buy this same thing
basically basically you're kind of
marketing yourself online to
different goals of people girls guys
whatever it might be
so let's say you got an ex-girlfriend
you want to get her back i'm not no i
don't recommend this but it happens all
the time
uh you know i'm saying you keep her in
your funnel which is instagram you keep
living your lifestyle you improve your
life
fitness uh maybe get a nice car maybe
get a nice house whatever it may be
and she's gonna see it first she'll see
the come up she's seeing your post
and i will tell you this right uh right
rich so many things our clients
even myself we get a text saying hey
stranger how you been
or like oh uh i missed you you know that
and it's funny because they would never
reach out to you
otherwise be missing your lifestyle so
it's very impressive bro
you